it's about damn time
it's about
damn time
go girl that was good lizzo blessed us
all with a must-see tick tock showing us
how she thinks different people would
sing her song about damn time
the pop star starts off with dialects
from canada and atl
how these different people would say
about damn time
it's a bit damn time
it's about goddamn goddamn goddamn
goddamn goddamn goddamn and then she
hits us with it's britney [ __ ] yes
britney spears
it's about damn time
and none other than
[Music]
me
adele
it's about
damn time
it's the head bob for me lizzo continues
the fun by doing an australian accent no
it's a bird during time
a news anchor impression and that was
the weather for today it's about damn
time back to you rick the star wars bear
aka chewbacca
but it doesn't end there lizzo caps off
her clip with a sound that's all too
familiar to ariana grande fans
perry po lizzo has a lot to smile about
right now on top of releasing her fourth
studio album special on friday this week
she earned six emmy nominations for her
dance competition series lizzo's watch
out for the big girls i'm looking for
dancers to join me on my tour girls that
look like me don't get representation
time to pull up my sleeves and find them
myself she used her platform to open the
show and like let me give these girls a
chance and we brought it here lizzo also
recently took the stage at the bet
awards and had a memorable appearance on
carpool
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
it down oh karaoke is so cool
it is like people
know my music well enough that i can do
this this is so cool but they're all
balanced that's the incredible thing
that's what i do
and let's not forget back in april she
pulled double duty hosting and
performing on snl enlisting her mother
to introduce her as she took the stage
once again my daughter lizzo
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm so glad that you're still with us
[Music]
now although the 34 year old has been
booked and busy when it comes to work
she's also found time to cultivate some
romance that's right in june when she
made her red carpet debut with her
boyfriend comedian and actor mike wright
i'm feeling good as hell
the two were photographed on the red
carpet for an fyc screening of her now
emmy nominated show and fans couldn't
help but notice a rock on lizzo's ring
finger wait what yep but as of now the
grammy winner hasn't confirmed a thing
whether it's official official or not we
love seeing lizzo in love in 2019 she
opened up to et about how difficult it's
been for her to find someone genuine
nobody tried to holla at me before all
this so if you're trying to holler at me
now i don't trust it there's got to be
something real about you or like you
just got to be fine as hell
either or everybody is in love with them
and everybody wants you everybody want
to smash everybody want to be your best
friend so it's like really hard to kind
of siphon through like the [ __ ] find
the real people